work in working with us through this
very difficult time there their
mutuality and partnership and
cooperation has been of great benefit to
the state so I want to thank them for
that I'm gonna make some opening
comments and turn it over to governor
Murphy first and then we'll hear from
the other governors I think most states
Oh operator we're ready started hearing
music okay Thank You governor's I just
said I thank you all very much for your
professionalism and your cooperation and
everything you've done that is benefited
this the alliance with the state of New
York and I also want to thank you and
congratulate you on what you've done for
your states it's truly been outstanding
and it's my honor to be a colleague to
you we've been talking today about the
fact that New York believes we have
reached a plateau in the increase of
number of cases they're not going down
but they're not going up at the same
rate and we believe it's a quote unquote
plateau and that is relatively good news
in a world of bad options and we should
start looking forward to reopening quote
unquote but reopening with a plan and a
smart plan because if you do it wrong it
can backfire and we've seen that in
other places on the globe so everyone is
very anxious to get out of the house get
back to work get the economy moving
everyone agrees with that what the art
form is going to be here is doing that
smartly and doing that productively and
doing that in a coordinated way doing
that in coordination with the other
states that are in the area and doing it
as a cooperative effort where we learn
from each other and we share information
and we share resources and we share
intelligence no one has done this before
no one on this telephone has done it
before no other state has done it before
so it's one step forward after research
and consultation with experts I'm not a
public health expert but this has to be
informed by experts and by data you take
one step forward you see how it works
and then you measure the next step and
to the extent we can do that together
that is the best course there's no doubt
about that
I don't believe we wind up with a fully
common strategy you have different
states in different positions within
this state you have different areas with
different circumstances and the plan has
to fit the facts and the circumstances
it's one situation in New York City it's
a different situation in rural counties
different situation in suburban County
so how do you address those different
set of facts and I want to make sure all
the people we represent make sure that
we are smart in the way we are doing
this yes we've never been here before
but that doesn't mean you can't ensure
public confidence that you're doing
everything you can to do it in a smart
way and inform the way guided by experts
and data and science and not in a
political way and I think working
together we can do that each state is
going to name a public health official
for that state and economic development
official for that state we that those
officials and the chief of staff of the
governor of each state will then form a
working group that will start work
immediately on designing a reopening
plan taking into consideration the
public health concerns and issues and
the economic reactivation issues
concerns study the data study the
research study the experience of other
countries and give us guidelines and
parameters to go forward again we
anticipate different facts different
circumstances for different states
different parts of States but let's be
smart and let's be cooperative and let's
learn from one another and that is in
arguable with that let me turn it over
to Governor Phil Murphy governor Murphy
thank you so much for being with us
Governor Cuomo's thank you for hosting
us so graciously and in the category of
you're known by the company you keep I'm
honored to be with you and governor
Lamont governor Wolf's governor Carney
governor Raimondo in this discussion and
in this initiative you know just as we
harmonized as States
you know we're do jerseys the debts of
state in America and we're in that that
corridor that is so unique it was
imperative to not just do the things
that we needed to do within our four
walls as we closed our state down but to
do it in close coordination with New
York and Pennsylvania and Delaware
Connecticut especially and it's that
same spirit that we're coming together
and acknowledging as we whenever it is
and and and by the way we have not yet
plateaued we're a couple of beats behind
New York our positive tests have begun
to flatten but we're not yet we're not
yet there but as we you know whenever it
is that we determine based on the facts
the data the science that it is safe for
us to responsibly begin the reopening
and all the healthcare infrastructure
that goes with that to do that in
coordination seems to be an
overwhelmingly prudent approach and
we're honored to be very much a part of
this group we do know this that an
economic recovery only occurs on the
back of a complete health care recovery
and that order is essential in getting
that wrong transposing those steps or
jumping in too early or maybe jumping in
by ourselves
Governor Cuomo and I have talked
about what if the protocols on one side
of the Hudson for a restaurant or a bar
different than the other or similarly
across the Delaware
you could have inadvertent unintended
consequences which could be grave so
getting this right both the timing the
infrastructure from as well as input as
Governor Cuomo I said from both health
care experts as well as economic
development experts in addition to our
government colleagues seems to me and
tell us to be an incredibly smart way to
go this is the this is the fight of our
lives let there be no doubt about it and
we're not out of the woods yet and
reopening ourselves back up will it be
equally challenging beyond the shadow of
a doubt so I'm honored to be with my
fellow governor's as I have been every
step of the way over the past several
months and look forward to that spirit
in coordination going forward thanks
Governor Cuomo thank you thank you very
much governor Murphy and you're right we
we started this journey together we're
going to end it together on a positive
note same with governor Ned Lamont from
the state of Connecticut governor Lamont
thank you very much thank you for being
with us Andrew thanks for getting us
organized and everybody here I'll just
pick up where a Phil left off he
mentioned the major transportation
corridors that interconnect at least New
York New Jersey and Connecticut as part
of a tri-state workforce and we all
slowly closed down methodically parts of
our economy and in a way that we tried
to mitigate the effects of the contagion
and we're going to be thoughtful about
how we get this opened as well but you
know Governor Cuomo's you know you know
all of our pandemic here in Connecticut
is all along that I 95 Metro North
corridor where we have hundreds of
thousands of people going back and forth
between New York and Connecticut it
it's the commuter corridor for us but
it's also the copic corridor which is
why it's so important that we work
together thoughtfully on this listen to
the experts as you say and make sure you
don't pull the trigger too early I'm
looking over at Japan and Hong Kong and
Singapore and those places are
unfortunately seen a small resurgence
the second half of the be coming back
again and that would be so demoralizing
for for our economy that's why what we
do I want to do when a coordinated basis
have a database that we share establish
the same protocol so we know how we're
working together and get that
information up to a van to Washington so
they can know coordinate as well I mean
we're going to be thinking about the mix
of PCR antigens and probably the low
infection areas in terms of testing and
probably the antibody testing in those
areas where it's more prevalent so we
can put together a system that allows
our people to get back to work and I
couldn't agree with each and every one
of you that working together makes the
most sense listening to the expert doing
this methodically but doing it now back
to you Governor Cuomo a men thank you
very much governor Lamont Thank You
Governor Tom wolf from Pennsylvania Tom
good to be with you again thank you for
doing this and thank you to my fellow
governors for making this effort
possible you know we we all know that we
can do anything better when we work
together in this region and we have done
good things by working together we've
shared ideas and plans and we've shared
in going through this this challenge and
this partnership this council that that
we're forming here recognizes that
simple fact and I agree with the
sentiments of my partners that we need
to do this right and that's what we're
trying to do but this partnership
recognizes something else that I think
is really important it recognizes that
we need to come up with a specific and a
smart plan for this uncertain future
that we it lies ahead but it is also
that we are creating a plan to let our
people the people that we serve the
citizens of our states that we indeed do
have a future and this is this is as
important as coming up with the specific
elements of this plan it has to be
responsible but it has to
show us that we do have a future as we
figured out how we're gonna reopen our
schools that we reopen our businesses
and our homes we're also going to
recognize that we're trying to figure
out how we're gonna restore the sense of
hope that this pandemic has taken away
from so many of us and I'm proud of the
people who are going to be working on
this for Pennsylvania the Secretary of
Health Secretary of the Department of
Community and Economic Development and
my chief of staff we're all gonna do a
great job for the people we serve and I
think we're gonna show the people the
United States how you come out of
something as devastating as this in a
responsible fashion
Governor Cuomo thank you again for doing
this and back to you Thank You governor
wolf thank you very much I couldn't
agree more with what my colleagues are
saying and governor Wolf's point we
talked about the economic toll which you
can quantify you can't quantify the
emotional toll this is taking on people
and I think governor wolf is exactly
right knowing that there's a another day
a new day coming may not may be
different than past days but it can be a
bright day and that is true and we have
to focus on that governor Carney very
good to be with you John thank you very
much for taking the time and all the
help and all the coordination Governor
Carney
yes doesn't hear me now hello can you
hear me now began well sorry for that
little glitch I want to thank my
colleagues for this cooperative effort
especially you Governor Cuomo for
bringing us together and frankly for
your leadership going on a day-to-day
basis basis under very difficult
circumstances there in Metro New York
City in your state's been do providing
great leadership there and across the
country and we certainly appreciate that
certainly thanks for including Delaware
of this region so we're connected
importantly by the i-95 corridor and
Amtrak Northeast region and so in a very
important way we're part of the region
if only a small part we have seen that
the connections among our state through
this as many of the folks who work in
our state live and the governor Wolf's
state or across the river in New Jersey
and they've obviously had to balance the
various provisions and restrictions in
each of our state's so this will help us
as we think through what it takes to
re-enter and to get our economy moving
again frankly it'll it'll really just
formalized for me what I've already been
doing along with governor's Murphy and
wolf in our Metro Philadelphia area as
we talked on a number of occasions about
decisions that we've had to make in
terms of shutting down businesses in
terms of business and supply chains that
are connected among our state's this
will formalize that and really put
before us all the decisions that we have
coming ahead of us and I think maybe
even more difficult than decisions on
the front end of this over the last
month and a half two months as we get on
the other side of the peak which it
seems like the Greater New York City
area is reaching now how do we
open things in a way that's safe I heard
governor Murphy say yesterday that we
need to get the patient healthy before
we can get the economy healthy and I
think he's exactly right in that and so
working together our economies are
connected our states are connected in a
real way in terms of transportation and
visitation and the rest and so our
working together sharing our information
and intelligence I think will help each
of us make better decision so I want to
thank all of you for your leadership
this is a time we're experiencing
unchartered waters here and I think
ahead of this book will be more
unchartered waters but working together
we will do a better job for the people
that we will we work for and we'll make
smart decisions in reopening our economy
we're a little bit different down here a
little bit behind I think those of us in
northern New Jersey and New York City
our message here at home still is be
fake stay at home when you go out you
know observe appropriate social
distancing and we will continue with
that method but at the same time think
about the timing of reentry and getting
back life back to normal again if that
ever occurs so again Governor Cuomo
thank you so much for including the
first state here in the southern end of
this region we appreciate your
leadership there and the great state of
New York and and your leadership with
this collab collaborative task force
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much governor Carney and you're so
right we're all learning right this is
new for all of us and it throws out a
lot of the old rules and the old ways of
doing business and the state boundaries
mean very little to this virus and
somebody can get on Amtrak or somebody
can get in a car and go up the i-95
corridor and it doesn't matter if
they're from Delaware or New Jersey or
Connecticut or New York what state
they're from it can have the same
consequence so we're learning and we're
growing every day thank you John and
governor Gina Raimondo from the state
Rhode Island governor Raimondo thank you
very much for taking the time to be with
us but thank you for working through all
these issues with us on behalf of New
York Gina Raimondo can you hear me yes
yes we can
hi good afternoon and thank you all and
thank you Andrew for leading us in
convening this group I think it's a
terrific initiative like all of you all
the governors who spoke and all the
governor's I've been speaking with I am
constantly thinking about what it's
going to take to safely reopen our
economy like you I don't want to keep
people out of work one day longer than
necessary however we need to do it
safely which means we need a smart
targeted approach to slowly reopen the
economy in a way that keeps everybody
most especially the elderly them
vulnerable and those are pre-existing
conditions safe so you know like many of
you I have a team here that I've
assembled to develop a plan for what we
are calling the new normal and we're
looking at everything from how we screen
people entering businesses to how we
utilize more touchless technologies and
our day-to-day interactions doing a deep
dive industry by industry on new
guidelines for this new normal and I'm
looking forward to this initiative I'm
looking forward to being a part of the
working group and exchanging ideas like
you have said we've never done of us has
ever gone through this before and I am
confident that by working together and
sharing our best ideas we will be much
much more likely to get it right for the
citizens of our state in this region I
will say you know throughout the crisis
the governors are the ones who've been
showing great leadership and taking
action to keep our residents safe and so
I think it's only appropriate that we do
the same thing now by coming together
and showing regional leadership to
reopen the economy
and as everyone has said I think if we
take a coordinated approach on a
regional level we'll be that much more
successful I know that over the past few
weeks I've spoken frequently with the
governor's on this call with governor of
Massachusetts governor's all around the
country and our ongoing collaboration
idea exchange coordination has certainly
enabled all of us to keep people safe in
our state the reality is this virus
doesn't care about state borders and our
response shouldn't either
so I am fully in support of this effort
and look forward to working with each of
you to make sure that we do get to the
business of getting folks back to work
and we do it in the smartest safest way
possible
thank you very much Tina thank you
governor Raimondo and I couldn't agree
more with all of my colleagues and
governor Raimondo spoink none of us have
done this before sharing information
learning from each other pooling
resources is only smart and we have to
be smart you need the best public health
plan and you need the best economic
reactivation plan it's not either/or it
has to be both no one is willing to
sacrifice one at the expense of the
other and you can't have one at the
expense of the other but how you do it
that's the art form we're going to take
questions for one question each from
each state and then I'll take questions
from New York afterwards
governor of the state of New Jersey
governor Murphy is ready for any
question from any reporter in the state
of New Jersey thank you as a reminder to
ask a question you will need to press
star from the number one on your
telephone again that's star 1 on your
telephone we've done vinyl we compile
the Q&A roster we will not allow the New
York reporters to question any other
governor I wouldn't
subject I believe it's this is Phil
Murphy Andrew I believe it's in our
Constitution that's not allowed
Steve co-operators you only go so far
I'm actually going to do our own press
conference at 3:00 p.m. so if there are
jersey folks on and they're not ready to
ask we're very happy to take them in
Trenton in a half hour so operator
anything we do have a few questions the
first one is from Charles Powell from
North from North Jersey hey Charlie no I
know okay good afternoon that the any
plan that you're divides will have to be
on any economic plan will have to be on
the back of a public health plan is that
your way of and it is collectively it's
a way of saying to the Trump
administration that we're going to we
disagree with your emphasis of putting
economy first that we feel we've most
earnestly and strongly have to make that
point that public health comes first
because you're not hearing that coming
out of Washington yeah Charlie I'd say
it good to hear from you by the way
I'd say it's less that for me in far
more let's just make the calls as we
have tried to make them from day one
based on the facts and the data and the
science and everything we're looking at
tells us you only get an economic
recovery if it comes on the back of a
health care recovery so our energies and
I think the council that we're forming
today speaks exactly to that in other
words the house is still on fire we
still have to put the fire out but we do
have to begin putting in in place the
pieces of the puzzle that we know we're
going to need both health care
infrastructure to make sure this doesn't
react well as the steps we're going to
need to take collectively as a region in
terms of economic recovery so I'd put it
much more on the category of calling
balls and strikes based on the data that
we're looking at and you know again I
think if you get that wrong you you
inadvertently even even with the
greatest of intentions if you transpose
those steps or if you if you if you Jam
it too early you could throw gasoline
even inadvertently on the fire and it
could reignite that's the last thing
that any of us need right now
so as painful as the economic reality is
right now and it's painful for all of us
it's not remotely as painful as it would
be if we get the sequencing wrong and or
the timing wrong thank you
well said governor thank you very much
for being with us governor Murphy
honored to be with you as always
thank you my friend operator state of
Connecticut Governor Ned Lamont do you
have any questions for many reporters
from Connecticut operator we do have a
question from Connecticut this line is
from cam Dixon your line is now open
hi governor thanks for getting together
disembodied way like this
governor Lamont I guess I'm trying to
figure out what kind of voice business
community's going to have as they're
part of the panel that you you've got
and I noticed the decd is going to be in
charge of that but how are you guys all
going to get together on a regional
basis it sounds like rather crowded bus
well what we are going to do can thanks
for the question is each have three
people on this committee and on behalf
of the state of Connecticut you talk
about business representation I've got a
great friend who's co-chairperson of our
economic Committee here for the state
and her name is Indra Nooyi who used to
be head of Pepsi so she'll be our
liaison to the business community here
in the state of Connecticut and part of
our liaison to all the other governor's
going forward and understands better
than anybody how urgent it is do we get
our economy going again but there's
nothing worse than a false start so what
that would do to confidence and what
that would do to the sense of hope that
Tom Wolfe was talking about
and that's why we will be announcing our
task force today in terms of how we go
forward with business and labor and the
scientific community in collaboration
with our fellow governors so we can open
this up prudently as quickly as possible
great governor thank you Thank You
governor thank you no to Lamont very
much for being with us today
operate or anything for the state of
Pennsylvania Thank You Ned next for a
mark levy
your line is now open hey Mark
hi can you hear me governor again hi
mark hi so we were wondering that with
the president saying that it's his
responsibility to reopen the state and
reopen the economy's we're wondering if
the governor's disagree that that this
is inherently a responsibility episode
well seeing how we hit the
responsibility for closing the state
down I think we probably have the
primary responsibility for opening it up
and and that sort of I think gets to the
question that I think governor Murphy
had and that is that between the
business and health and I think that's
that's a false choice I think this
regional compact is premise tone the
idea that you're not going to have a
healthy economy if you have an unhealthy
population so we've got to do both we've
got to get people healthy the sequences
you got to get to help people healthy
first and then you can reopen the
economy not until where the economy is
not going to I can work so so I think
what we're trying to do is is we have
tried all of us governor's working
together have tried to to have the hard
stop that we need to make sure that we
remain safe as we could possibly can
with this pandemic and we're now ready
to go into the next step which is to
start moving back to some sense of
normal of the new normal and and do it
as we as we have working together here
in the in the in the region so I don't I
don't think you know we're trying to say
anything negative about anybody we're
simply saying it was our responsibility
to steer our way through these uncharted
waters and it's our responsibility to
figure out a way back
thank you very much Tom thank you
governor wolf we have operator do you
have any questions for the state of
Delaware
[Music]
stayed up thank you very much again
appreciate very much your leadership
both what you've been doing over the
last very difficult week with the
experience there in New York City in the
great state that we pray for you'll be
thinking about you affect you for
concluding dealt the state of Delaware
in this in this caliber for the good
work thank you John thank you my friend
very much I wish my leadership in the
state of New York was as good as yours
and I had no questions whatsoever about
my decisions
maybe you teach me a few lessons thanks
for being for being with us John
governor Gina Raimondo operator you have
any calls for state of Rhode Island we
don't have any questions for state of
Rhode Island
you made these continued yeah another
governor who shows me up good to be with
you Gina thank you very much for taking
a turn thank you Andrew for doing this
and for all that you've been doing and I
appreciate the leadership because this
region is one of great economic activity
and I I know we're gonna have a better
shot at getting it right working
together so I'll have my team on it
somebody from commerce somebody from
health and my chief of staff and we'll
lean into this to make sure we all get
it right so thank you and thank you all
thank you very much thank you okay
I think first I think the governor is
very much we've been working together
for a number of days obviously we've
been working all through this with many
of the states on a daily basis again
nobody's been here before nobody has all
the answers if they say they do they
don't know the question in my opinion
addressing public health and addressing
the economy which is first
they're both first you can't do one
without the other
it's a false choice to move the economy
forward you have to address
to address public health you have to be
addressing the economic reactivation you
have to do both at once there parallel
tracks that's why we have the head of
Economic Development the head of health
and then the governor's chief of staff
from each state so we have a total
Council of 18 we're still talking to
other states and he states who want to
join or welcome to join and again it's a
sharing of information
come compare notes compare experiences
sharing of university resources
scientific resources and coming up with
a plan that is consistent if not
complementary one state to the other and
certainly not where one state does
something that is counter to another
state which could happen and I've seen
that in the past
so governor Murphy for example from New
Jersey's point that what you do in New
York just pushes people across a bridge
to another state if it's not consistent
that is exactly right his workforce is
my workforce my workforce is his
workforce all of these decisions affect
everyone and the entire region what this
virus says is all of your lines and
boundaries make no sense I can get on
the Amtrak train and get off anywhere
along that line and if the person is
positive can in fact scores of people so
you're all interconnected we've talked
about it for a long time but this makes
the point questions any sense of
timetables deadlines for this working
group you're going to start talking
literally tomorrow and start to scope
that out we didn't start with a
timetable we said and we'll say to the
group we wanted ASAP but we want it
smart this is about being smart
first not political smart follow the
data learn from the other countries
people other countries
have done this you're seeing mixed
information and mixed data learn from
the other countries coordinate set of
guidelines ASAP but smart oh it has to
be within weeks it has to be well look I
would say let's see what the federal
government's plan is governor Wolf's
point was right he left it to the states
to close down and that was a
state-by-state decision without any
guidance really he took the position
that it was a state's decision and then
the states were responsible for
purchasing supplies etc so that was the
model of Management for this disaster
emergency that was promulgated thus far
if they want to change the model they
can change the model he's the president
of the United States he is the federal
government and it is still civics 101
federal state local government he wants
to change a management model we look at
the laws state governance federal
governance let him change a model
consistent with the Constitution
consistent with the law but then change
the model and explain it what does that
mean the federal government is in charge
of opening are you going to say when
each state can open or should open are
you going to set a formula and that says
any jurisdiction of X population that
has X infection rate should be open or
closed any population of X infection
rate these are the activities this is
what can be on public transit this is
what can be on the roads any
jurisdiction that opens must have the
following precautions you must have a
mask you must have gloves you can do
that that could be a model where they
set a federal program
that the states can follow and should
follow but then you have to be specific
testing states don't have the capacity
to test it's not as simple as saying
states should test they can't do it
without the federal government there are
not enough tests now and there's not
enough reagents and there's not enough
medical equipment any one of these
governor's would tell you on the phone
they don't have the testing capacity and
they can't gather it themselves so you
want to change the management model you
can do that as president but what is the
model and let's learn from the past
right because this was not smooth
sailing up till date let's be honest no
I've not had this conversation let's
learn from the past what does the
federal government do and what does the
state do tell me what are the roles
what's my responsibility what's the
federal responsibilities you want to
shift the responsibilities in the
relationship fine I'm open to it
explain to me what I do what they do who
dis purchasing who pays who does testing
I can't open what open it when open it
how how do you different differentiate
between New York City
Albany Buffalo Nassau Suffolk do I do
the schools at the same time that I do
businesses do I do the transportation
system at the same time that I do
businesses what happens if I don't have
enough transportation workers do I still
open the economy even though I don't
have enough transportation workers to
run the trains you want to make those
decisions tell me you want to make those
decisions and then make them in a way
that states can follow or say option B
federal government does this states you
do this you decide what the percentage
is I don't want to you decide what the
appropriate time is to open and what
functions I don't want to you can do it
any No
of ways but it has to be clearly defined
you're talking about States under the
states I didn't have to tell the cities
what to do I have to tell the counties
what to do I have 500 mayors I have 50
County executives I have to say to them
this is the plan because each one of
them wants to come up with their own
plan right so I can't have you want to
tell me what to do fine but then I have
to be able to turn around and tell my
local governments what to do so the
clarity here is important and it's nope
there is no conceptual answer this is a
very specific answer I have to operate
every day my life is all about
management and operations that's what I
do right now
I communicate the truth to the people of
the state every day and I have to manage
the operation and that's every day I
have to tell every day I have to tell my
local governments what to do every day I
have to tell the schools what to do
every day I have to tell the hospitals
this is what's coming on PPE every day I
have to tell the hospitals this is how
we're going to balance the patient load
that's what I have to do tell me how I
do my job
visa vie the federal role and
responsibility but yeah you're President
of the United States you want to put
forth a management model let's hear them
what parts of the economy are shut down
down for your priority
I wouldn't do that I don't know I
wouldn't tell you that you'd have to
that's part of this study what business
do you open when what is the best thing
they all have a conversation but for
example if you don't have the
fundamental systems aligned you have
nothing if you want to open business
schools have to be open to any large
degree you want turn the valve a lot
schools have to be open why because you
can't open businesses if people don't
have childcare well I'm saying you have
to align the systems you want to open
businesses you have to have the
transportation system open that'll be
the starting point for the conversation
or you could say I'm not turning the
valve that far we're gonna ease into it
we're gonna phase into it and this is
how we're going to do that that's what
this group has to discuss and then New
York will have a strategy each state
will have a strategy hopefully they're
not inconsistent I would love to do
everything in unison as the optimum if
unison isn't possible because we're
different and we have different needs
fine but let's at least know what each
other is doing so we're not
counterproductive with each other claims
kind of overarching powers when you and
the other governors seem to be dealing
with kind of the nuts and bolts of this
nothing frustrating nothing's
frustrating everything's frustrating and
it's not about an emotion I just want
clarity
governor Wolf's point is right the
states closed it is an interesting
construct that it wasn't the federal
responsibility to close the economy but
it is the federal responsibilities of
the federal government's responsibility
to open the economy if it's your
authority to open why wasn't your your
authority to close right that's an
obvious question and when you say open
what does that mean
does that mean you're gonna proclaim all
businesses open isolation over come out
of your homes businesses are open what
does it mean
governor's need clarity that's what they
need you're the president there's a
Constitution there may be legal
questions what's a federal
responsibility with the state
responsibility but the government Lee
the president has a lot of lawyers so if
it is a legal construct you're President
of the United States you want to put
forth a disaster emergency plan as
president that's your right and by the
way this is a federally declared
disaster you know I was in the federal
government and the rules of government
matter there is an operating manual
states can declare disasters and then
the state is in charge over the local
governments federal government declares
and declares an emergency the federal
government is now in charge and they
have done a federal emergency
declaration here well why was it been
widened the federal government make
decisions on closing I don't know could
they now say we're going to make
decisions on opening yes
I don't believe they could have a policy
that says everybody opens five days from
now how do you differentiate different
parts of the country with different
infection rates different places on the
curve somewhere at the apex somewhere at
the plateau some are on their way up the
mountain how do you do that
differentiation are you gonna do a
formula that says any place with an
infection rate less than 2% can open you
know how do you do it I don't know but
he could put forth a model to do this
Victor what was the first part of that
question no there is no there are no
actions to take the law on the situation
is clear I understand
we have about 700 school districts I
understand we have about 500 mayors I
understand we have about 50 County
executives I understand everyone has a
voice and has a role here this is a
state emergency the state will follow a
uniform plan or a statewide strategy
Nassau Suffolk Westchester New York City
Schools I closed at the same time why
because you have to close all the
schools in the metropolitan region at
the same time there's too much
interconnectivity to do it it also has
to be coordinated with the business plan
that is the only way it can work
we had a total hodgepodge of decisions
with different school districts opening
in different school districts closing
all across the state I came in said a
statewide closing policy that is the law
that is what governs local school
districts say well I normally make the
decisions to open or closed yes you
normally do not in this situation
because this is a state emergency well
you're disrespecting this day the county
of Suffolk I'm not but we're one state
and we can't have every local government
making independent decisions from every
other local government that would be
mayhem second you just heard the
point which is the state then has to
coordinate with other states so I have
to be able to say in New Jersey and
Connecticut and Delaware and Rhode
Island
here's what I'm doing as a state I can't
have seven different policies within my
state here's my state policy how do we
conform and there's another question
where the president's going to say or
could say the query I don't care what
you say governor I'm going to assert my
jurisdiction over the state because this
is a federal emergency and the president
could say which is the query of the
question the federal government will
determine what the states do so I
understand
I have mayor's call me I have County
executives call me I have school
district officials call me they all have
an opinion I value all of their opinion
but we have one state and the state will
operate as one and their decisions must
fit within that plan or they're not
valid if the federal government comes
and says they're going to substitute a
federal plan well that would then Trump
a state plan pardon the pun if it fit
within the Constitution and the law go
ahead of course yeah let me do the first
round of questions first okay all right
Nick do a question and then we'll come
back
the ventilators yesterday to a facility
in this unit knock on wood right now it
looks like there is less of a need for
ventilators do you think some of them
get returned to us and the other
institutions if if big guy because if we
are at a plateau and on the numbers that
we've all seen it looks like we're
reaching a plateau slight uptick still
right day-to-day but a flattening we are
we've done so much work and acquired so
many materials and equipment etc that we
are fine NOC Formica
if we don't go up that's why we returned
to 35 ventilators to the nursing home
also because the nursing home was so how
beautiful
I'm just how beautiful they just
gratuitously called up and volunteered
35 ventilators nobody even called them
and asked from a nursing home which is
the most vulnerable place and vulnerable
population so we returned to 35
ventilators we are fine so to speak from
an equipment point of view right now if
the number doesn't go up and to the
extent anyone we borrowed ventilators
from upstate New York we can return them
whenever they need them or as soon as
practicable but if they need them today
I can get them tomorrow
I'm sorry what happened to the
ventilators
we ordered 17,000 I think we wound up
getting about 3,000 that actually came
in I think it would be waiting for a
long long time I think what happened was
there were so many places competing for
the orders in China that they kept
upping the price and they took on next
order like I was basically we were
bidding against every other state in the
country so they would say the ventilator
is $25,000 I would order it at $25,000
and then another state would come in and
say I'll pay 30 and our order just
basically got bumped the some of the
orders the factories are saying we can
get it to you in six months
I don't need ventilators in six months
we need them now so we've gotten about
3,000 I don't think we have any serious
ideas that we're gonna get more do you
know guys know all different vendors
these are all Chinese companies I don't
know their names but we that's what I
said on let's learn from what happened
what sense did it make that the FEMA
says we don't do purchasing which is by
the way what they used to do right I was
there I worked with FEMA I was the HUD
secretary they used to purchase that's
what they did it's a federal disaster
FEMA came in and was the logistics
coordinator in this case they said it's
not a federal responsibility is up to
the states every state had to go out and
buy ventilators and PPE in masks lo and
behold the main manufacturer becomes
China so you have every state calling
these Chinese companies literally
through brokers trying to buy
ventilators price goes through the roof
everybody's competing with everyone I
mean it was total madness so that's why
I say
you want to change the rules that's your
prerogative but what are the rules and
do they make sense for example testing
states cannot test I'm telling you right
now I do not have the capacity to do
these tests
I can't purchase enough diagnostic tests
or equipment so an opening plan that
says you must open by the way you must
test I can't do the tests we have we are
talking to we are not talking to Canada
I don't believe we're talking to a
number of states about who we're
coordinating on certain elements not
other elements but this is a relatively
new situation this today's coalition so
we'll continue talking anybody wants to
join in the Northeast is welcome the
more information you shared the smarter
the plan the better can't be bad the
council from each state head health
official from each state and governor's
chief of staff from each state three
people from each state six states 18
people and it will be a public health
strategy and an economic development
strategy if it's like this you can't do
one without the other you have to do
both and you have to integrate them in
one plan and I have to represent that I
have one statewide plan for my state my
whole state will function that way you
want to divide it into down state
mid-hudson up state by number of cases
that could be theoretically a suggestion
from the from the Commission Council but
yes those will be the guidelines and
then it has to be smarter because you're
just sharing Talent you're sharing
reason
forces the best minds from six states
are the better best better than best
minds from just any one state right by
definition so it'll be smarter
it will also be cooperative and
collaborative where if Jersey and
Connecticut put forth a plan that is not
coordinated with New York it hurts our
compliance and remember we're asking
people to do very tough things if you
say well you can just go of course the
river and you have a different set of
rules then people will get in their car
they'll go stay with their
brother-in-law who lives in New Jersey
with a brother-in-law who lives in
Connecticut and they have a different
set of rules his restaurants are open
our restaurants are closed you know what
happens everybody drives to that state
to go to dinner that's all that happens
it was the same point when we are
talking about marijuana
right and the rules on marijuana if you
don't conform those rules people will
just shop jurisdictions complicating the
issue though with six different states
six different agendas six different
situations on the ground doesn't it make
it more complicated in a way you don't
have a choice but to coordinate because
if another state you are subject to
whatever any surrounding state does
anyway my bars are closed okay
Connecticut's open I'll go to a bar in
Connecticut I'll go to a bar in New
Jersey
or I'll go to a bar in Massachusetts no
but we're talking to Massachusetts also
so by definition if you do not take that
fact into consideration then you're just
being blind to the facts well I can't
get on the same page a hundred percent
with another state I don't expect you to
but to the extent you can avoid
contradictory policies that's better and
maybe you won't even be able to avoid
contradictory policies you know
Connecticut could say I'm opening my
bars and I feel very strongly and I'm
sorry to be discordant but I'm opening
my bars and New York doesn't want to
open their bars don't open your bars but
I'm opening my bars all right
at least then we see the clash and we're
aware of it and you know you try to work
it out if you can't we'll get out you
can't work it out but at least you know
about it you have a conversation
facilities will be one of the issues
that's on the agenda but my guess is
again we talked about this morning
density you do not want a lot of people
in a small space that is the last thing
you want because that is the breeding
ground for this virus I mean that is
goldfish shooting fish in a barrel right
you put a lot of people in one room all
you need is one person that's the New
Rochelle lesson one person went to a
social gathering religious gathering
infected hundreds at one gathering all
right
thank you very much schools are closed
schools in New York City closed schools
in Nassau are closed schools in
Westchester closed schools and suffered
have closed schools across the state are
closed
schools across the state will stay
closed until we say they are open they
are closed until the state says they are
open they were closed by an executive
order that said all school districts in
the state are closed they will remain
closed until the state says they were
open the state waived was called 180 day
requirement that said they had to be
open for 180 days to get funding we will
waive that requirement as long as the
state says they are closed and that's
where we are closing the schools was a
hard decision because we knew once you
closed the schools that it would impact
businesses and impact the workforce and
there was great fear that nurses
wouldn't be able to go to work etc
because now they had no child care we
reached the point where we said we
understand that when we closed all the
schools the situation I was very simple
all the schools are closed
well this school district wants to
reopen I know there are 700 school
districts there are 700 opinions there's
one state there's one state policy
it couldn't be clearer it couldn't be
simpler thank you very much guys
some teachers have reached out and said
that you're equating the education
system to daycare is that an inaccurate
education system by practical reality is
when you close the schools then you have
to have an answer for where to the
school where the children eat whether
they get breakfast whether they get
lunch where do the parents get massive
amounts of daycare so they can go to
work even though the schools are closed
you have to answer those these are all
practical issues that are